bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo chill où nous
allons parler de la série de viols qu
est tous qui l'entourent je trouve qu'il
ya pas mal d'éléments intéressants a
souligné concernant le show pour le
moment sachant qu'en plus la série fera
neuf épisodes et puis ça ne fait pas mal
de faire un petit point cela va me
permettre de vous partager ma vision des
choses mais théorie mais également de
voir ce que vous vous avez en tête
concernant cette dernière bien
évidemment la vidéo va spoil les trois
premiers épisodes de la série scholtes
donc vous êtes prévenus sur ce
commençons la première chose importante
dont il faut que nous parlions et ça
peut sembler idiot pour certains mais
c'est la réécriture que nous propose à
chaque fois le marvel cinématiques
universe vous le savez aussi bien que
moi l'univers des films et des séries
s'inspire des comics pour nous proposer
dû contenu mais la grande majorité des
éléments sont remodelées pour coller à
l'intrigué et l'histoire que marvel
studio souhaite mettre en place et je
sais que c'est évident pour beaucoup
mais le truc c'est que cette réécriture
possède un énorme impact sur l'univers
et permet de souligner les prochaines
grandes lignes du futur de marc bêtes
par exemple prenons l'origine des
pouvoirs de jennifer walters dans les
comics jennifer en tant qu'avocate va
défendre un gangster qui malheureusement
était en conflit avec d'autres criminels
ce qui va déclencher des représailles
contre jennifer walter scott qui se fera
tirer dessus et du coup au bord de la
mort jane a besoin d'une transfusion
sanguine pour pouvoir s'en sortir
néanmoins personne n'a le sang qui
correspond aux siens seul son cousin
bruce banner possède le même sens ce qui
va pousser ce dernier a donné son sang à
sa cousine et du coup c'est ce qui la
fera devenir chien yolk par la suite
alors que dans le mc eu et ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'il modifie ce genre
de choses l'origine des pouvoirs de
jennyfer et provoqué dans un accident de
voiture à cause d'un vaisseau spatial et
où elle est avec son cousin brousse qui
va permettre le mélange de sang cette
réécriture est intéressante car marvel
était obligé de faire intervenir banner
seul lui pouvait donner l'opportunité à
walters d'obtenir ses pouvoirs mais du
coup ils en ont profité pour intégrer
une intrigue secondaire concernant hulk
et cette intrigue et bien maintenant
elle est là on ne peut plus retourner en
arrière hulk et banner ont maintenant
une voie de sortie et un avenir dans le
mc eu et c'est ça qui est important de
par les éléments qui ont été instaurées
dans la série il est clair à à 100% que
marvel souhaite développer la période un
petit peu sombre ou hulk a pris le
dessus sur banner avant de faire son
retour dans thor ragnarok rappelez-vous
suite avengers l'ère du le tronc hulk
que ces autos banni de la terre estimant
que cette dernière ne les met pas son
vaisseau s'est finalement craché sur une
drôle de planète ça car et là bas le
grand maître a finalement fait d'ul que
son champion sauf que pendant près de
deux ans banner étaient absents et hulk
avait la totalité du contrôle et encore
on parle de deux années par rapport à la
terre car sur ça car le temps s'écoule
plus vite si nous reprenons la série
chaulk le vaisseau qui a provoqué
l'accident de voiture est un des sceaux
provenant de sacs à rebrousse
l'utilisent même pour partir dans
l'espace donc voila tout semble tracée
banner repartirait sur ça car par
rapport à ce que hulk a pu faire là-bas
durant la période où ce dernier avait le
total contrôle après bah maintenant tout
est désormais possible et peut-être que
nous aurons certaines réponses dans la
série shake d'après certaines théories
populaire et je suis totalement en
accord avec ça c'est que cela pourrait
être l'intégration du personnage de ce
car le fils de hull ce qui est
intéressant avec cette idée c'est que
dans les comics durant la période de
hulk était présent sur ça car il s'est
marié avec une femme qui est tombée
enceinte par la suite malheureusement à
cause d'une rébellion ces derniers a été
tué sauf que ce cadre est finalement née
du coup hulk a quitté sa car pour
prendre sa revanche sur les illuminati
qui l'avait bannie à l'époque et ne sera
alors jamais que son fils a survécu dans
les décombres de ça car actuellement
tout est mis en place pour retranscrire
cette histoire dans le mc ça car a été
ravagé et une rébellion acomptes dus
puis à faire tomber le grand maître ce
quart aurait donc pu naître dans les
décombres comme ça l'a été dans les
comics banner apprenant l'existence du
fils de hulk serait en route là bas pour
le rencontrer et cela déclencherait une
nouvelle histoire mettant enfin en
vedette le personnage de hulk car on va
se le dire hulk a besoin d'avoir sa
production dédiée parmi les premiers
avengers il est le seul à ne pas avoir
été mis au devant de la scène dans une
production solo si on ne compte pas
l'incroyable hulk de 2008 qui est plutôt
particulier malheureusement vous le
savez aussi bien que moi hull que
n'appartient pas à marvel c'est
universal pictures slash paramount qui
possède le personnage et c'est pourquoi
ça a toujours été compliqué de
développer hulk depuis tout ce temps
maintenant il y à des rumeurs comme quoi
l'appartenance de hulk à universal
prendrait fin en 2023 permettant à
marvel de récupérer définitivement le
personnage mais dans le fond on ne sait
rien des véritables accords entre les
studios et c'est ça qui bloque néanmoins
ce qui est clair c'est que marvel cache
quelque chose à propos de hulk et avec
tout ce qui est amené dans la série
shulk on entend clairement vers un
projet solo dédié au personnage surtout
que cela pourrait redorer le blason de
hulk qui est mis au second plan depuis
des années et cela permettrait d'amener
de nouvelles histoires qui s'intégrerait
bien à l'univers effectivement la hausse
car pourrait devenir un antagoniste au
rove foulant son père qui estime l'avoir
abandonné sur ça car comme dans les
comics et bien à terme nous pourrions
avoir l'intégration de la femme ils
veulent qu une team de super-héros
composé à 100% de hulk avec notamment
banner she walks car et même pourquoi
pas la domination mais en tout cas voilà
ce qu'ils ont amené dans chignole que ne
peut désormais être ignorée une intrigue
pour hulk est en train de se dessiner en
fait c'est comme pour les autres shows
monica rambo par exemple elle a été
amenée dans one la vision et finalement
elle va avoir sa véritable apparition
par la suite dans ce marvel ou même par
exemple faucon et le solde à l'hiver on
nous apporte une intrigue liée au wac en
dha et bucky puis dans le futur une
série sur le wac en dha est censé être
produites donc voilà vous avez compris
ce que je veux dire maintenant espérons
qu'il ne laisse pas cette intrigue de
côté comme ils l'ont fait avec le wave
est jeune mais sincèrement je pense que
nous pourrions avoir des surprises lors
du d23 le week-end prochain bon et
maintenant recentrons nous sur la série
shulk et son avenir dans le mc pour le
moment à part concernant l'origine story
et la série semble adapter la série de
comics chez yolk de 2004 à 2005 nous
retrouvons son licenciement à cause du
procès perdus nous retrouvons également
le recrutement de jennifer par holden
holly way pour intégrer son cabinet dans
une division dédiée aux super héros est
également la multitude de cameo tout le
long de la série marvel studios aime
beaucoup prendre une saga de comics pour
lancer une série puis par la suite ils
vont piocher dans des éléments un petit
peu plus généraux pour agrémenter et
enrichir l'histoire l'exemple qui me
vient le plus rapidement en tête c'est
le cas de moon knight ou comme on en
parlait à l'époque ils ont repris les
comics des années 60 70 pour l'origine
story du personnage puis nous nous
sommes tournés principalement vers
l'histoire des comics de jeff
l'émailleur est bien là du coup cela
semble être la même chose marvel a
repris les vieux comics concernant
l'origine story de jennyfer appuie
désormais nous nous tournons plus vers
l'histoire de la saga she hulk de 2005
et du coup bah si l'on suit ce procédé
nous devrions continuer dans la série
l'adaptation des comics dont je viens de
vous parler pour deviner en gros les
grandes lignes de l'histoire pour moi il
ya deux éléments très importants de ces
comics à retenir afin de pas trop
rentrer dans le spoil déjà la première
chose c'est que l'antagoniste principal
de l'histoire c'est titania bon on s'en
doutait un petit peu par rapport aux
informations que nous avions avant la
sortie de la série puis cette dernière
est apparue dans le tout premier épisode
il se pourrait donc à très fortes
chances que la jeune femme souhaite se
venger par la suite surtout que titania
est quand même la grande rivale de
chiottes néanmoins la série semble
cacher autre chose concernant les
potentielles menaces et nous allons y
revenir dans un instant et du coup pour
finir le deuxième point que j'estime
très important c énorme présence de
cameo dans la saga en fait chaque comics
de chez yolk de 2005 met en lumière une
histoire liée à d'autres super héros et
après tout c'est plutôt normal puisque
la condition de jennifer walters d'être
une avocate liés aux superhéros 8 permet
d'en rencontrer énormément par exemple
dans cette même saga il y un comics ou
she hulk va rencontrer spider man un
autre liée aux quatre fantastiques ou
encore avec hercules et c et c est la
série semble prendre le même chemin
jennyfer casse même le quatrième mur à
un moment donné pour souligner cet
élément nous avons l'origine story puis
nous avons eu le caméo de hulk de
l'abomination ou encore de wang tout ça
en seulement trois épisodes et il y a de
très grandes chances que cela continue
dans cette lignée revenons à ce que je
voulais vous dire concernant les
potentielles menaces l'épisode 3 de
chiottes a intégré le groupe de
démolition en gros c'est une équipe de
vilains qui ont pas mal affronter tort
dans les comics et du coup ils ont
réécrit le groupe pour en faire une team
de vilains qui ont tenté de voler le
sens de jennyfer et travaillant
apparemment pour quelqu'un de plus grand
pour être honnête je ne vois pas
quarante mille possibilités concernant
ce méchant secret qu'il souhaite voler
le sens de chiottes je vous renvoie vers
ma vidéo dédiée à la série aux cayes
pour en savoir plus mais pour moi il ya
clairement deux personnages qui se
démarquent considérablement concernant
toutes les histoires un petit peu plus
classique et terre-à-terre et en rapport
avec tout ce qui est gouvernement etc il
s'agit bien évidemment de valentina
allegra des fontaines et du coup bas du
caïd alias wilson fisk en fait valentina
nous a prouvé au fil des séries quelle
est l'origine de la future team des
thunderbolts ce elle a déjà recruté john
walker elle a aussi trouvé et jelena
belova il y a de grandes chances qu'elle
soit aussi lié aux caïds et en plus de
cela dans la team des thunderbolts il y
a le red gulch donc je me dis que
pourquoi pas valentina souhaiterait
récupérer le sens de jennifer pour
donner naissance un futur membre de la
team des thunderbolts étant donné que
banner est tout le temps caché dans son
labo secret et désormais il n'est même
plus sur terre donc c'est beaucoup plus
simple de voler le sens de chiottes et
de l'autre côté il se pourrait que le
vrai king crew soit aux ordres de wilson
fisk un peu comme le gang des survêt
dans hawkeye le caïd possède désormais
un grand avenir dans le mc eu et tout
comme valentina il ya de très grandes
chances pour qu'il soit relié à la
plupart des intrigues je vous le
rappelle mais je suis partisan du fait
que le damage control qui est apparu
dans nos héros mme ou encore miss marvel
et qui ont récupéré les travaux de tony
stark soit secrètement aux ordres du
caïd comme c'est le cas dans les comics
et du coup en tant que grand patron de
la pègre et bien ce ne serait pas
étonnant de savoir que l'organisation de
wilson souhaite récupérer le pouvoir que
détient chiottes mais ce n'est pas tout
et c'est là où la thématique des caméo
est importante car comme vous le savez
nous en avons été témoins par le biais
des thrillers d'art des villes est censé
apparaître dans la série et matt murdock
c'est le plus grand ennemi de wilson et
les deux adversaires réapparaîtront à de
multiples reprises dans le mc eu comme
la série eco la série dédiée à daredevil
et caetera et c'est donc il se pourrait
que cette intrigue liée aux vrais king
crew et le sens de chiottes ce soit ce
qui va permettre la rencontre entre ces
dernières et daredevil pour nous
proposer un début de scénario pour matt
murdock dans le mca et du coup je suis
très curieux concernant les possibles
autres caméo car nous pouvons vraiment
avoir de très grosses surprises
personnellement
j'avoue que je rêve un peu mais s'il ya
bien quelque chose qui me ferait qui
fait c'est d'avoir la véritable première
apparition de rides richard's des 4
fantastiques dans la série ce qui me
fait penser ceci c'est que nous le
savons le film quatre fantastiques de la
phase 6 ne sera pas une origin story ce
qui veut dire que les 4 fantastiques
peuvent apparaître avant dans le mc car
il n'y a pas besoin de les intégrer
d'expliquer leur pouvoir et cetera etc
en plus de cela il a été récemment
dévoilé que reed richards devait
possiblement apparaître en scène post
générique dans doctor strange multiverse
of madness il y avait comme idée de
pourquoi pas faire apparaître le ried
richard's 616 celui de notre réalité en
train de regarder les événements du film
depuis le baxter building donc ce qui
nous prouve qu'il ya un véritable désir
actuellement d'amener reed richards
dedans le mc sans oublier également que
les 4 fantastiques sont très proches de
shylock dans les comics jennifer walters
a remplacé la chose pendant un très long
moment elle a fait partie de l'équipe et
nous pouvons noter aussi que daredevil
et dans les comics l'avocat des quatre
fantastiques
étant donnée la mise en lumière de
jennifer walters dans le mc u et la mise
en place d'une division d'un cabinet
d'avocats dédié aux affaires de super
héros pour moi il est tout à fait
possible que reed aimerait rencontrer
chez yolk pour qu'elle puisse devenir
l'avocate du groupe pourquoi pas vivant
à new york et travaillant régulièrement
avec le gouvernement reid est quelqu'un
pour qui la loi est importante et c'est
quelque chose qui caractérise le
personnage daredevil dans les comics est
devenu très tôt l'avocat du groupe du
coup je me taille peut être un peu tout
seul mais à voir impossible caméo de
rides richard's souhaitant que jennifer
soit leur avocate baj me dis que ce
n'est pas impossible mais bon cela ne
veut pas dire que cela va arriver dans
tous les cas attendez vous à voir
d'autres caméo dans la série chaulk
marvel nous cache des choses
et écoutez je pense que nous allons nous
arrêter ici c'était une petite vidéo de
schille pour faire un petit peu le point
sur la série shulk et le personnage de
banner et hulk et bah j'espère que cela
vous aura plu nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de la série n'oubliez pas
qu'elle fait neuf épisodes donc voilà
vous pouvez compter sur moi en attendant
j'aimerais vous renvoyer vers ma
dernière vidéo où je met en lumière
l'histoire complète du docteur doom ou
fatalis si vous préférez c'est une vidéo
très importante pour moi qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à aller la voir je vous
renvoie également vers la chaîne de mon
bourreau de toujours eros f qui lui
aussi vous a sorti une vidéo sur la
syrie chaulk au moment où je vous parle
et où j'apparais de dents sur ce
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de
laisser un petit pouce bleus s'étaient
argot rock que la layan soit avec vous
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]